Pakistan is expelling India's ambassador
and suspending trade ties as a result of
Delhi's move to revoke the economy of
its part of Kashmir the region remains
in lockdown for a fourth day now with
security forces on high alert with shops
closed residents say they're running out
of fresh food telephone and internet
connections have also been caught and a
curfew remains in place well in a heated
session of Parliament Pakistan's foreign
minister Mahmoud coracii had this to say
we are linking our Independence Day
celebrations with the right of
self-determination for Kashmir ease and
from free Kashmir to Indian Occupied
Kashmir and from it to all the bazaars
streets towns villages and cities of
Pakistan we will say in one voice
Kashmir will become Pakistan okay let's
go straight now to Delhi I'm joined by
our correspondent there at the Mesha ice
wall - Misha the Pakistani Foreign
Minister setting out a very clear goal
there
how far is Pakistan prepared to go to
make Kashmir a part of the country
well Brian the first thing to establish
here is that this region has been
claimed by both neighbours Pakistan and
India in its entirety ever since the
partition of India
so Pakistan has made this claim about
wanting to claim all of Kashmir for
itself for the past 70 years but when it
comes to how far it's willing to go I
mean of course two wars have been waged
between India and Pakistan
over the region and now after India's
latest move Pakistan has downgraded
trade and diplomatic ties with the
country with India India has also
responded encouraging urging Pakistan
not to do so but Pakistan is also
prepared to appeal to the international
community the United Nations has weighed
in urging both regions both countries to
become and to not to not take up
military action but right now of course
Pakistan has July
on international backing and in the past
as well has continuously encouraged the
international community to weigh in
because they say that kashmiri should
have a plebiscite as was once planned
that the Kashmiri people should get to
watch of course when it comes to India's
perspective India believes and has
continuously alleged that Pakistan has
fuelled insurgency in the region so
according to India Pakistan would be
willing to increase that but of course
the line of control between India
administered Kashmir and
pakistan-administered Kashmir remains
tense and the region itself is in
complete communications lockdown because
of which the families of Kashmir is in
Delhi are very worried because they
haven't heard any news from home for
four days yesterday there was a protest
in Delhi which we went to and this is
what we learned from Bharat Kashmiris
Nasir is on his way home he does not
know if he will be back because he does
not know if he will survive home is
Kashmir a place under lockdown ever
since India scrapped the special
autonomous status the state has enjoyed
for 70 years on his way to the airport
Nasser stops by this protest held in
solidarity with fish movies the last he
heard three days ago was that his mother
was feeling unwell he does not know if
she made it to the hospital last words
she said to me I am not feeling well
tomorrow is my appointment to the Soraa
Medical Institute and that tomorrow we
face the deployment of thousands of
paramilitary forces on our doors so she
could not access she could not reach out
to the doctor which I don't know whether
my family is alive or not
NASA and the protesters have three
demands reversed the government's
decision lifts the communications
blackout and release arrested local
leaders many young Kashmiri
in Delhi to work and study have joined
in they have had no word from whom gosh
we will never accept that Kashmir is not
come there are reports of violence that
are pouring in except that we have no
ways to confirm whether it's true or not
which makes us all the more answer
and worried for our families and the
Modi state will have to answer this for
someone like me who has lived
independently for eight years now I
haven't known the feeling of
homesickness for eight years and it's
for the first time in eight years that
I'm feeling homesick that I want to go
home because my parents don't know why I
didn't turn up at the airport I don't
know if they went to the airport to
fetch me despite fears for their own
safety if they protest openly they don't
know what else to do as voices for and
against the government decision
reverberate across the country Kashmir
itself is silent a complete clamped down
on journalists and communications
blackout has meant that anger fear and
frightening rumors about the safety of
loved ones back home run rampant yes
some scoff at these worries claiming
that any protests against the
government's decisions are anti national
and baseless this group has shown up to
shout down the protests against the
government who are you to stop the
government's progressive order what is
your intent is the ISIS funding you or
anti India foreign forces funding you
who are you as anger boils over on both
sides
Kashmiri czar trying to decide whether
it is better to mobilize protests here
or try to reach their families for
Nasser despite the risks he knows he has
to head home he has to at least try
Nimisha your report points to all the
tensions inside India and between
Pakistan and India at this point can a
further escalation between Delhi and
Islamabad be avoided at this point well
Bryan in the past as well when tensions
have risen between the two countries and
they have come very close to an
escalation but somehow at the last
minute a de-escalation has been made
possible and there was another
escalation earlier this year in February
but of course it's also important to
point out that the action India has
taken in India administered Kashmir is
unprecedented and is massive when
compared to the last 70 years of India's
interventions and India's decisions when
it comes to its own parts of Kashmir
also it's important to point out that
both countries are making statements
through a ever since this decision has
been made today
Pakistani Prime Minister Imran Khan is
expected to speak Indian Prime Minister
Narendra Modi is speaking to the nation
over the radio at later this this
evening and that's also something that
is not a norm so both of these are of
course about the issue of Kashmir so a
further escalation is something that the
this region as well as the international
community is worrying about however I do
have to point out that according to
India this has not been an act of
aggression according to India this move
has been about integrating cash meat
further into the country about bringing
development to cash nearly is about
granting Kashmiri opportunities of
course perspectives on the opposition
claim that this is not the right way to
do it so we will have to wait and watch
to see if both countries choose to stick
with diplomatic and triggered actions or
if military escalation is possible
further along the line of control
between the two parts of India at
Kashmir and pakistan-administered
Kashmir Nimisha jaiswal for us in Delhi
thanks very much for that